first let me address Bob man cough I
could write that every day and so you
tell Bob man cough no big deal I have
lots of cartoon ideas and and I don't
see what he's bitching about actually
even off the new yorker cartoon it's
what they write one like once every
three years or something right
big deal it's like they're one sentence
apiece give me a break for a while I
can't draw at all but I was trying to
teach myself how to draw got a book
because I was I was going to write my
own a draw my own cartoons but then I
got lazy and I really can't draw so um I
have a friend Tom gamble out in LA who's
a wonderful cartoonist and I I sometimes
send him suggestions for cartoons which
he never makes but like I just had this
is a great one tell you tell Bob minkoff
this is a great there's a man and eat
stomach ache he's very unhappy and his
wife walks in with Al Capone and he says
you idiot I told you to bring home alka
seltzer like that's a--that's a
prize-winning cartoon right there I just
thought of that one the other day um yep
similarly though and in all seriousness
um it yeah it's that ability to do it
every day and it's that ability to it's
not just perseverance it's um it's
talent and it's it's treating it like a
job you any time here of a writer who
says he's waiting for inspiration I say
that's not a writer it is absolutely
it's a job it's a career you can you can
not feel like writing you can be dry as
a bone and you have to sit down and
start writing there's you can't tolerate
something like writers block especially
on TV but I suppose if you're when
you're writing a book at home you know
you can give yourself a couple of days
like that but it's it's being able to
dredge it up every day and and produce
it it's not just this romantic pure
creation it's it's a job
you